how old do you know the English alphabet
how how far did you graduate did you
graduate high school college or anything
yeah I graduate college you graduated
college so you're familiar with the
English alphabet correct right all right
do me a favor can you just say the uh
English alphabet from the letter c
Charlie to letter W whiskey okay don't
sing it just say each letter out loud
for me all right CDE E F G H I J K L MF
o g h i j k l m f o g
G it's hard right well take your time oh
Q R S T U VW that's where you want to St
okay all right it I mean it's I mean
it's hard to do I it's not something you
do every day absolutely I get it I
understand you need anything particulars
no not at the moment you can just hang
with
on walnut walnut and my my ex-husband
came there and like confronting me okay
so all
right stand over here yeah
I'll is this your car so this is so a
friend of mine is doing like
construction on their house okay and
it's their car that they like parked at
my house need a Teleport too
okay I was coming from my friend's house
on Walnut Street on Walnut Street where
you going I was just going
home where were you driving to where you
coming this way
or
okay how you feel right
now huh yeah no I mean you feel good I
mean I was upset like that's
why okay what were you doing at your
friend house anything particular or no
she's just having trouble with her like
her boyfriend I was just there my
husband came and and like caused the
commotion so I left are you heading home
to mhm all
right have you had anything to drink
tonight
no
okay how do you have any head injuries
or anything no did you hit anything no I
mean I'm fine well just stay here I mean
I'm fine you're fine yes
okay just stay
here is this your car no so my friend is
doing construction on their house and
and so I have their like for the
summer do you
live
go notified be
in can I get
it give your ID yeah go ahead and go get
your ID for okay go ahead go ahead walk
over are you going or you want me to you
get your
ID yeah
yeah
you going to do it or you want him to do
it I think it's his his
dis if you want me to do
it huh
what you have your uh your license
yeah everything came out of my
purse see all my
stuff the
accident
got can what's your first name Tam
Tamela Tamela Tamela can you come here
real quick
please come here let me get your ID and
then just come back here real quick
please
31 uh this is her ID who wants it I'll
take1 you're 31 2357 you have Delta 3
with
you I have two and one and uh
Sergeant all right um Tamila how you say
it Tamila Tam all right do me a favor
okay I'm just gonna put this light up
because I want to see your eyes real
quick I'm G just put you through some
test all right I just want to make sure
you're okay yeah I mean I was just upset
I mean I know it's okay but I'm going to
be honest with you I'm just going to
tell you what it is okay talking to you
I'm not the only one that observes it
but we can smell an Oda of alcohol
coming from you that's why I asked you
did you do anything before you came out
tonight or before you drove you said you
was at a friend's house you didn't say
anything else but like I said smelling
OD of alcohol coming from you okay um so
right now I just want to perform some
tests to see if you're okay if you're
okay we'll help you get home or whatever
the case is and that'll be that for the
night okay so do me a favor just look at
my
finger okay just follow the finger okay
don't move your head do you have any
head injuries any concussions or
anything that we need to be worried
about are you wearing any contacts at
this time all right just keep your eyes
on the finger and just follow the finger
okay
okay so we just going to do some tests
now just follow the finger all right
don't move your
head
no keep your head
straight
one last time
okay okay one last thing just going to
check going up okay just follow my
finger keep your head straight
[Music]
want to pull one of your vehicles up
just so we
can you say you're not hurting anywhere
no no body parts hurting at this time no
not at the time okay you want to get
checked out at all by the squad or
anything I feel I feel good you feel
okay all
right how about this how old do you know
the English alphabet how how far did you
graduate did you graduate high school
college or anything yeah I graduate
college you graduated college so you
familiar with the English alphabet
correct right all right do me a favor
can you just say the uh English alphabet
from the letter c Charlie to letter W
whiskey okay don't sing it just say each
letter out loud for me all right c d e f
g h i j k l m f l g h i j k l m f o
g it's hard right well take your time Q
RS Tu U V W that's where you want to S
okay all right it I mean it's I mean
it's it's hard to do I got it it's not
something you do every day no absolutely
I get it I understand once uh they pull
up the card will uh go with the test you
have no injuries to your feet no
injuries to your where you can't walk or
anything like that no I have a hip
injury from from working out but that's
it okay all right no problem they're
going to pull up the car and put the
cameras on us we're going to give you
like two more tests once you do those
two tests and he shows that you're okay
we'll help you out maybe try to get you
home try to figure out what's the next
step from there okay for you all right
I understand my brother's a cop I I
totally understand oh he
is
okay where is he a cop at Arlington
Texas
okay all right that's the family gotta
all
right
mm did they move uh yeah
upload
okay you said he was helping out a
friend you were talking to okay how did
that go she was going through some
things I mean she's still with him
so it's up you can help people as much
as you want but it's up to them to
decide I
guess so not successful
but go this way cuz this is like more in
a downhill so so um do me a favor just
step over where this officer is just
walk over to that
officer all right before you start she's
good on medical attention I asked her
several times she said no she doesn't
want any medical attention they huh
they're asking before they clear do you
want to once again you have one Mark I'm
fine you're fine yeah okay she says
she's fine okay all
right all right do me a favor follow
this line go stand on that line line uh
where the light is facing to towards
your right facing towards your right
facing yeah all right I'm going go I'm
going tell you exactly what you need to
do once I tell you to start that's when
you start the test okay so in order for
you to start this test I need your both
of your hands down at your side okay I
need your left foot on the line pretend
there's a line in front of you put put
your left foot on that line and directly
in front of it on a heel to toe manner
put your right foot in front of your
left foot hold that position do not
start do not move until I tell you to do
so okay M all right when I tell you to
do so you're going to take nine Hill to
toe steps all right you're going to
count out
loud once you get to your ninth step
you're going to take a Sit you got to
stay in that position no I I'm I'm n I'm
nervous okay which is fine I understand
but once again you got to stay in that
position that it put you in I'm
listening to you okay so but I need you
to stay in that position that I told you
that left foot on the line your right
foot directly in front your hands down
at your side okay I need you to stay in
that I need you to stay in that position
okay until I tell you to do so you're
going to take nine Heel To Toe steps
once you get to the ninth step you're
going to take a series of small steps to
turn back around and you're going to
take nine Heel To Toe steps going back
I'm going to demonstrate the test for
you before you begin okay pay attention
to what I'm doing I want all right I'm
going I'm going to take three steps
you're taking nine okay one
two three I'm taking three you're taking
nine on your ninth step you're going to
take a series of small
steps and you're going to go back one
two three once again I'm only going to
do three you're going to do nine okay
once you get down to the ninth step
you're going to stop you're going to
take a series of small steps to turn
back around and go back okay when I tell
you to begin your hands have to stay
down at your side you have to count each
step out loud and you once you begin you
cannot stop do you understand what I'm
saying so nine
steps he to toe once you get to that
ninth step you're going to take a series
of small steps tur it back around to go
back okay do you understand what I just
gave you the instructions all right I
need you to get back in the starting
position like I asked you this is the
third time now the starting position I I
understand I didn't know we need to be
there whole time mean this is like an
elevated step I'm in heels well do you
want to take your heels off more than
you you can definitely take your heels
off to make it easier for
yourself okay you can telling you this
is an emotional accident I promise you I
listen I'm I'm you're going to get
arrested for emotional like that's what
this is excuse me you can get arrested
for like an emotional no I don't I'm not
saying I should have been driving
because I was emotionally upset okay
that's what it says well once again
we're also doing a test to see if you've
been drinking I understand okay so once
again I need you to get back in the
starting position with your hands down
at your side I need your heel to toe
Manor it's worth you me to roll up my
pants it's up to you whatever is going
to help you uh do this test right doing
so I just want you to
see all right you back in the starting
position correct M left foot on the line
right foot directly in front yes it's
nervous all are you ready yeah are you
in your starting position correct do you
need me to go over any part of the test
for you nine steps nine steps then what
turn small series of steps to turn
around to come back I'm just nervous I'm
nervous now I understand take a deep
breath we're not here to get you in
trouble we just want to make sure you're
okay I know I'm just nervous cuz I was
in an accident and I'm I'm nervous okay
well listen the sooner we get this over
with the sooner we can possibly get you
home okay understand all right hand down
at your side okay you're going to count
out loud you're going to take nine steps
heel to toe touching M all right and
you're going to take a series of nine
step uh small steps to turn back
you may begin
[Applause]
good
all right so what we going to do we're
going to do one more test okay this this
next test is called I'm going to just
move this to the side for
you this next step uh next test is going
to be the one-legged raise okay you're
going to pick a leg of you're choosing
whichever leg you feel comfortable okay
the starting position is going to be
feet together hands down at your side
that's the starting position I need you
to get into that for me please get into
that position for me down at your side
when I tell you to begin okay you're
gonna pick up one leg of your choosing
okay you're going to count out loud 1
1,000 2 1,000 3 1,000 until I tell you
to stop okay when you begin this test
your has got to stay down at your side
wait pick pick it up I'm going to
demonstrate it for you okay okay I'm
just going know if it's like front back
is up to you once again I'm going to
demonstrate it for you okay
m hands down at your side you pick your
feet of your choos and pick it up in
front of you nine inches okay you're
gonna go one 1000 2 1,000 3 1,000 4
1,000 5 1,000 until I tell you to stop
okay whichever fee you feel comfortable
that's the one that you want to pick up
by all means you can pick it up until I
tell you to stop all right do you
understand the instructions I'm giving
you yes I need you to say it out loud
yes sir yes it's okay you got a
timer you got
it hands down at your side all right
whenever you're ready go ahead and pick
up your feet pick up one foot 9 in off
the ground count out loud for me
okay 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15
16 17 18 19 20 21 22 23 24 25 26 27 28
sorry my cor is not what it should
be all
right all right so this is what I need
you to do okay I need you to turn around
put your hands behind your back okay
unfortunately for tonight you are going
to be arrested for DUI okay I I haven't
done anything but turn around is there a
balizer like well we are going to go
down we're going to go back to
headquarters from you'll do that part
all right for for right now you're being
plac under
arrest sorry I'm getting caught up in
your
shirt
hold on one
second
joh coming for two vehicles of which
one
just
not so I
um anything else that's it I mean I'm
very I'm very stressed good when did you
take
have anything drink with
it you have one beer I am I distressed I
am in a horrible divorce
I you need anything from your
car you need anything from inside your
car your
Pur my purse
yeah can I show you yeah
well I think she just had it that one
right there the white
one this one yeah and there's a wall
underneath
W this yeah this pink one right here
yeah so all that I don't know who opened
that but that is that your medication
yes and my key do you need this
medication yes what is
it subcribe to of
course this credit card M your car keys
ke M here's driver's license in there
anything else you here like my my
prescription my credit
you okay all right put it in here
prescription what else anything else the
key to the car there's another
key I'll take care of the
keys make sure you your your house key
right
here we're going to take that off and
we're going
to please leave it on cuz that's not
even same for that's that's my other car
oh there's a different car yeah the
key the key to the Jeep is right there
okay it's in the it's in the all right
man all
right all right good you good anything
else you need for
me all right by right
guys put your shoes on
yeah a minute a minute
going to go on my feet are
wet I'm really just upset listen we're
not
saying like like we get it is this a
shitty moment you want to just well yeah
he's getting he's getting the car you
don't get
a you don't
have no you just put her in put her in
one for now until he's getting my car
right now I
[Applause]
have
[Music]
be you right man no my ex husband's
going to like absolutely murder me over
this but
why because he was that's why I was so
upset in my rock and he's threatening me
I mean this is is that his car yeah
that's my friend from
Texas walk over to that car that car
comes hold on hold
on
just checked
up what's
happening go grab a seat grab a seat you
can go what what do you mean go grab a
seat okay like the whole thing I know
just sit down and then I'mma grab the
seat
[Music]
belt so all we got to
do
put the no the I got put it
on
huh all
right she unless just be operating more
vehicle more of it I say do more of a I
think I smok it that's why I was like
she definitely was
drinking
the see I was telling I I didn't see the
eyes I know well no that's why some
people are
T it's my test you I can't do a test
even now yeah I I I have balance issues
like you know like give the one leg
stance like
my legs are too weak right I don't
do legs I just felt that cuz after we
called that out that we were doing
it her brother's on in
Texas
nothing of you want to follow him in
yeah
uh I'm going to hang up the car you
going to I guess you'll do the 17
portion well yeah I'll take care of it
it's just this car all the information
is in the glove box with is Stu so I
can't get the insurance or anything out
the
GL transer one of female from this
location headquarters starting mileage 5
9 4
34.9
okay transport one female from this
location headquarters SAR the mileage 5
9 4 3
49 71
F beginning time
8 all
right
[Music]
this is
just
round back ending marage
[Applause]
okay I'm okay no don't want you to fall
over we
[Applause]
got
watch your
[Applause]
step